bitte nehmen Sie Platz
ich öffne die Sitzung des Zweiten Senats
des Bundesverfassungsgerichts zur
Verkündung einer Entscheidung in dem
Verfahren zur verfassungsrechtlichen
Prüfung des 19 Gesetzes zur Änderung des
Bundeswahlgesetzes vom 25 November
Antragsteller erstens Ingrid Arndt
Brauer und 144 weitere Mitglieder der
Fraktion der SPD im Deutschen Bundestag
zweitens Kerstin Andree und 68 weitere
Mitglieder der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen im Deutschen Bundestag zwei
bf3/11 in dem Verfahren über die
Verfassungsbeschwerde des Herrn Ralf Uwe
Beck sowie weiteren
3.062 Beschwerdeführern gegen die
gesetzlichen Bestimmungen des § 6
Bundeswahlgesetz in seiner am dritten
dezember 2011 in Kraft getretenen
Fassung zwei BVR 2670
Jahres 2011 sowie dem Antrag wird sowie
die in dem Verfahren über den Antrag
festzustellen dass der Deutsche
Bundestag durch Beschluss des 19
Gesetzes zur Änderung des
Bundeswahlgesetzes vom 25 November 2011
die Antragstellerin in ihren Rechten aus
Artikel 21 Absatz 1 und Artikel 38
Absatz 1 des Grundgesetzes verletzt hat
Antragstellerin ist hier Partei Bündnis
90 die Grünen Antragsgegner der Deutsche
Bundestag zwei BV E9 aus 2011
erschienen sind
für die antragstelle des Verfahrens zwei
BVF 3 aus 2011 die Herrn Abgeordneten
Volker Beck
[Musik]
Thomas Oppermann
sowie als Bevollmächtigter Herr
Professor Dr harzi Hans Meyer
für die Beschwerdeführer der
Verfassungsbeschwerde 2 BVR 2670 aus
2011 Frau Abgeordnete Halina vacinak
sowie Herr Professor Dr Matthias Rossi
als Bevollmächtigter
[Musik]
für die Antragsteller des Verfahrens 2
BVE 9 aus 2011 Frau Prof dr Ute
sakkowski
für den Deutschen Bundestag die Herrn
Abgeordneten Dr Günther Krings
dr Stefan Ruppert
für die jungsdirektor Lippold Freiherr
von Bredow
sowie die Herren Professor Dr Bernd
und Herr Professor Dr Franz schorkopp
als bevollmächtigt
für die Bundesregierung aus dem
Bundesministerium des Innern Frau
ministerialrätin Dr Monika Fahrland
sowie Herr Professor Dr Heinrich lang
als Bevollmächtigter
für die ökologische demokratische Partei
herr Werner Rolf
für die Piratenpartei Deutschlands Herr
Sebastian Nerz
für der Statistische Bundesamt der
Präsident des Statistischen Bundesamtes
rodrig-egeler
als Sachverständiger Auskunftsperson
Herr Prof Dr Christian Hesse
es wird folgendes Urteil verkündet
im Namen des Volkes die Verfahren werden
zu gemeinsamen Entscheidungen verbunden
Paragraph 6 Absatz 1 Satz 1 und Absatz
2a des Bundeswahlgesetzes in der Fassung
des 19 Gesetzes zu Änderungen des
Bundeswahlgesetzes vom 25 November 2011
sind mit Artikel 21 Absatz 1 und Artikel
38 absatz 1 Satz 1 das Grundgesetzes und
vereinbar und wichtig
6 Absatz 5 des Bundeswahlgesetzes in der
Fassung des 19 Gesetzes zu Ändern des
Bundeswahlgesetzes vom 25 November 2011
ist nach Maßgabe der Gründe mit Artikel
21 Absatz 1 und Artikel 38 absatz 1 Satz
1 des Grundgesetzes und vereinbaren
die unter Nummer römisch 2 Ziffer 1 und
2 bezeichneten Bestimmungen verletzen
die Beschwerdeführer des
verfassungsbeschwerterverfahrens in dem
genannten Umfang in ihren Rechten auf
Gleichheit und Unmittelbarkeit der Wahl
nach Artikel 38 Absatz 1 des
Grundgesetzes
der Deutsche Bundestag hat euch
Beschluss des 19 Gesetzes zu Änderungen
des Bundeswahlgesetzes von 25 November
2011 die Antragstellerin des
organstaltverfahrens sowie dem
organstaltverfahren beigetretene
sonstige Beteiligte in dem aus Nummer
zwei Ziffer 1 und 2 ersichtlichen Umfang
in ihren Rechten auf Chancengleichheit
nach Artikel 21 Absatz 1 und Artikel 38
Absatz 1 des Grundgesetzes verletzt im
übrigen werden die Anträge im
Normenkontrollverfahren und im
organstaltverfahren sowie die
Verfassungsbeschwerden zurückgewiesen
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland hat den
Beschwerdeführern des
verfassungsbeschwerdeverfahrens ihre
notwendigen Auslagen zu erstatten